what is it that goes I have to go after
my dream when is that moment so I was 23
years old I had just graduated college I
always knew I wanted to get into
stand-up comedy and then I I me and my
sister we drove out to Los Angeles from
Chicago and I arrived in 1998 and I just
wanted to make a living doing stand-up
comedy there was no backup plan there
was like no time limit uh oh I'm going
to do this for 5 years I was in it and I
always love making people laugh and uh
here I am on the drw Barry morph I
mean I really so excited to meet you
because I feel like the way people talk
about you also is like this very
proprietary like you are theirs they are
there's a connection there and what do
you think it takes to be authentically
yourself and not and keep people with
you because it's a risk you know uh I
just I'm honest when I talk about my
comedy I'm I'm I'm honest with my
relationships uh primar primarily my dad
that's why I talk a lot about in my
comedy of like his way he grew up the
way he uh raised my sister and I I also
talk about my wife my wife's side of the
family so I'm kind of does your wife
ever be like I I don't want to be on
this one or like or she like no fair
game no my wife has got an amazing sense
of humor her whole family is very cool
with me kind of poking fun my my
mother-in-law was just with her
Thanksgiving and people ask her do you
mind that he makes fun of your family
and she's like as long as he's putting
food on the
table I don't care what he says so um
are you a mama's boy I am I'm a mama's
boy uh my mom is I don't really talk
about her in my ACT which which she's
kind of upset about she's like where am
I is it cuz she's so sacred yeah for me
you know like Mom Mom could do no wrong
I mean plus my dad's a huge personality
so he just got a lot more to say and a
lot more point of view but my mom's kind
of like just just like you know sweet
little sweet little mother by the way is
it true that like turning 50 you had
something about like well I'm at 50 I've
got x amount of time to go is that true
I I turned 50 this year and I start to
think okay I got what 25 years left if
that maybe maybe maybe 30 uh so I also
feel like people are getting very greedy
with life
expectancy 95 yes it's like you're the
Smuckers or you didn't make it yeah like
if you didn't become a centurion and the
blue zones isn't helping it's making I
don't know I'm I feel a lot of pressure
there's a lot of pressure to live to 153
years old yes and I feel like if you're
not in an ice bath or a steam room uh
you're failing I don't sleep I didn't
sleep last night I don't know what you
guys did but I was up you know uh till
till 2:30 3:00 in the morning just you
know cuz doing what I have sciatic pain
ripping down down my right leg like you
wouldn't believe and and apparently I've
been sleeping wrong my whole life people
say you got to sleep with a pillow
between your legs I'm like when did that
start I mean I I sleep face down like I
was shot and and now I can't feel my
shoulders anymore so I don't know I've
been well I have to say I don't think
you've ever looked better you're like
veral fantastic I do hope you live
forever because anybody needs you on
this it
however Marina our producer showed me
your uh is it your first 8 by10 can I
share it with everybody go ahead go okay
you guys have got to
hello
what this is uh was that from the
portrait studio you were
working this was actually off the side
of a freeway in Chicago where this
photographer took me and said uh we're
going to we're going to set you up on
this uh with like I don't know there's
like cornstalks behind me so that was my
it wasn't 8 by 10 that was an 8 and 1/2
by 11 I
went so I could stand out in a pile Oh
my God what's this is this big you're
standing out in that picture if you're
going into the comedy business or the
porn industry that 8 by10 works either
[Music]
way